I was ranked three times in the world
trading championship day trading
division and I was vice champion for two
times with a total performance of 350%
over 9 months and here are the best
trades I took in the competition and why
I took them. So let's start from the
beginning of the session and we can see
that uh before the starting of the
session it was almost uh 12 uh central
central European time we had some kind
of balance here the market was really
trying to understand where to explode
and also on the upper part the profile
was was really clear. We didn't had a a
clear direction here. We had the market
trying to break out on the upside to
break out on the downside. And if you
only use price action in this moment,
you are pretty confused. You think that
nothing interesting is happening and you
you just think that you need to wait.
But volume was telling us something
different. And I want to start today uh
letting you understand the power of the
cumulative volume delta and the concept
of the volume spread analysis. This is
one of the one of my most profitable
trading session that I had in the
quarterly world cup of robins and it's a
super directional session and I just
capitalize on the market collapsing on
NASDAQ and I will let you understand why
there is a big difference between
watching only price and adding volume to
your narratives. Let's start with the
situation we are in from the price
action perspective. We can see that the
market is balanced at this time and if
we plot a profile for the current
situation we can just see balance and
there is the fair value on the middle
there is no clear direction but let's
start with the first leading volume
indicator that is cumulative volume
delta to try to understand if in this
moment we were building some kind of
pressure. Let's start with the
cumulative volume delta and let's
compare the two. So the market was
balanced at this time but as you can see
the direction from the pressure of the
market and cumulative volume delta is
pretty huge even before the breakout. So
the market is clearly building pressure
down. This is the delta of the volume
and the we are in a condition of
accumulation and distribution. This in
this specific case this is a
distribution. Now I receive a lot of
inquiry and questions and Fabio can you
please clarify this? How can I diversify
and understand if you are in a condition
of accumulation and distribution? This
is the way because the volume is leading
the price. So the volume is showing us
that we were distributing and we were
ready to explode short. But this is not
enough. This is only the first milestone
for my trading model. So I will add the
second confirmation that you can get
from this. I will remove the cumulative
volume delta and I will go inside the
deep trades model now. So big trades
it's an indicator that we are developing
in our proprietary platform and it's
something that is really giving us an
edge in understanding where the big
players are pushing the price. So what
we can see at this moment is a clear
balance condition in the market and the
first moment that we had some kind of
follow up on volume and confirmation
from price was exactly this candle. This
was my first position because the market
told me Fabio we are going down the
volume pressure is down and we have the
price action that is following up. So I
have the first position here. Now for
those who follow me and understand my
strategy, my way of trading is keeping
draw down really low, building uh the
profit for the day and then risking
again the profit. So what I'm seeking
and what I'm searching for the session
is explosion in market movement. And
this is exactly what I want. This is the
first confirmation that we are in a
condition of out of balance. We we were
in distribution for all the session. Now
we are starting to go down. This was my
first position, exactly this one. And
this was, if I'm not wrong, this was 30
of December. So, we were on the final
days of the competition. We were
head-to-head with Nazaran. And the first
position went to break even immediately.
So, the market exploded in my direction
and I put my stop loss to break even.
The first stop loss was
here. So the risk-to-reward was pretty
huge on this position because if we can
consider that I closed this
position, the first position was
closed around here. It was uh almost 1
to three even more 1:5 risk-to-reward
ratio. Uh this is one of my way of
managing position sizing is when the
market is giving me another confirmation
that the sellers are pushing the price
down. I put my first stop loss to break
even and I can consider to close the
first trade and open a second one with
the profit of the first one or just
continue to add to my position in
direction of the trend. Then I was uh in
live commentary with my business partner
and this was the first position. This
was the second position. This was the
third position. And then I closed all
these trades here in the second
accumulation phase. Why? Because I start
to see that the big trades are not
pushing anymore the price down. We are
in a redistribution phase. And this is
another concept that is not well
understood by traders. They try to guess
if we are in a accumulation or
distribution only using price action.
And this is something that is not really
convenient. So from this moment I waited
and I took some profit and I use half of
this profit to risk again. And again as
you can see is as clear as possible. You
see again the the price action breaking
down. You see again big trades in the
direction of the trend because we
studied auction market theory and we
know that this is a sell model day and
we continue to sell and this was another
huge takeprofit because I use part of
the profit in this position. So we
already commented like we already had a
commentary of five different position
that were trailed as the market was
moving. Another position because I
closed the session around four. Another
position that I took was this position
and this is another model that I use. As
you can see the market is breaking down.
Okay. And I see that the big trades is
holding that the price is trying to
retrace the buyers are trying to take
control of this market condition but the
results is almost zero. So to do this
kind of analysis I usually use the delta
profile footprint. So we will now open
the profile footprint and the cumulative
volume delta and we can just zoom
in on what was happening at this moment.
And as you can see I was using volume
spread analysis. So the direction of the
pressure of the volume and the result of
the price in this exact moment this
exact candle the result of the price for
a pressure in by delta was almost zero.
So this is a confirmation that the
buyers are punching a wall and I want to
be short in this position. So this was
again a short position again a short
position and as you can see as soon as
the market approach the all-time low for
the day you see big traders sell
continuing to push down. This is your
opportunity to put the risk to zero to
put your position to zero and again the
market collapse. I took profit for this
position at this level. That was the low
of the day and I was sitting at a huge
profit for the day. So I didn't continue
to load my position during the evening.
But this was my most profitable session
on the World Trading Cup. So, if you
like this video, let me know in the
comments if you like this kind of
content.